[Music]
it's firm back as I can remember I
always wanted to create YouTube videos
with tips for screenwriters to me being
a youtuber was better than being a
president of the United States and today
we break down arguably the best gangster
movie ever
Goodfellas it's a true story of gangster
Henry Hill an adaptation of the book
wiseguy by Nicholas Pileggi who also
co-wrote the screenplay which crew says
yeah my my name is Marty Scorsese said
well I'm calling it because he said I
just read your book he said I've been
looking for this book for years I said
well I've been waiting for this phone
call all my life and the rest is history
the screenplay was nominated for an
Oscar won a BAFTA and interacts number
41 on Writers Guild of America greatest
screenplays lists whenever I come across
this movie on TV there goes my next two
hours I have to watch it but why this
movie is so intriguing to watch well so
many things but let's start at the
beginning
tip number one create an intriguing
opening scene in Goodfellas we have a
flash-forward opening scene which is
also called a fabulous structure meaning
that in the beginning we show a scene
from writer in the movie and having the
audience question how we got there it's
a screenwriters tool that can work or
not so make sure you have a good reason
to put it there let's see Wesker says he
decided to do it and then Marty was
looking at it you know it's a little
slow this is a movie we gotta do so so
we took that out of the middle of the
book put it in the front and he says
when he they kill him put the trunk down
then I'll freeze on Ray Liotta looking
out and then BAM you're in the movie
twist banaji explained Scorsese thought
the script was too slow so he needed to
hook the audience that was the first
reason the second reason was that this
scene was always interesting to him
reason number three the scene is
shocking because of the brutal violence
number four the scene has mystery to it
what's the noise in the trunk number
five the scene is perfectly compact so
it gives a lot of information and
exposition in the least possible time
number six it perfectly sets up the
violent and dangerous world in which
Henry will be operating in and the most
important ingredient of the opening
scene it must raise a lot of
questions for the audience so after
seeing that scene our minds are racing
with questions who are those three
brutal guys who is this guy in the trunk
how and why did they kill him but the
opening scene wouldn't be perfect
without a great scene ending and this
scene ending is so amazing
they became most quotable line in
gangster movies ever as far back as I
can remember I always wanted to be a
gangster so with this line we perfectly
end the opening scene while at the same
time we hope the audience for the rest
of the movie is Billie wiser said grab
him by the throat and never let him go
so now we have the audience hooked but
now we have another problem will the
audience want to follow Henry as a
protagonist who is obviously not a
decent person
and here's where likeability and
voiceover come in which will be our tip
number two and tip number three let's
first take a look at likability tip
number two how to make antihero likable
so Henry is not a good man he steals he
beats people up and he cheats on his
wife yet somehow we must make him
likable enough so the audience will want
to watch the movie with him as the
narrator so how do we do that the first
trick is we must play on the empathy not
on sympathy and John to be perfectly
explains the difference between the two
in his book the anatomy of story the
trick to keeping the audience's interest
in a character even when the character
is not likable or is taking immoral
actions is to show the audience the
hero's motive if you show the audience
why the character chooses to do what he
does they understand the cost of the
action empathy without necessarily
approving of the action itself sympathy
so now let's see what writing methods
should you use to make the audience feel
empathy for the unlikable hero
first thing is you must start out loving
him
Scorsese skillfully structured the early
portions of the film where Henry is
enthusiastic and likeable and because of
that we then remain sympathetic to him
throughout the movie second make him an
underdog a small-time low-level wannabe
who works hard to make his dream a
reality
audiences love her struggling character
who goes after his dreams third make him
excited to me being a gangster was
better than being president of the
United States for making me surrounded
by far worse guys
than him Henry is far less cold-blooded
and violent than Jimmy and Tommy and he
doesn't kill anybody in the movie so
because his friends are murderous
sociopaths in comparison to them Henry
doesn't look so bad v when he does
brutal things
let them be at least in some way
justified for example in the scene in
which he takes revenge on a neighbor who
upsets his wife he is shockingly violent
but the scene is designed with a
deliberate tinge of twisted morality
because he is defending his wife 6 make
him do little good and sensitive things
let him puke when he is digging up Billy
batts corpse so we see him as a bit
vulnerable let him make dinner for his
disabled brother so we see him as a
caring person
7 Kennedy is conciliating with everybody
and doesn't bust anybody's balls for the
money he's kind of a peaceful negotiator
when Jimmy or Tommy gets too violent
with their victims other characters in
the movie all like Henry and that makes
the audience like him also there is one
more great device we can use to make
Henry more likable and that device is
voiceover with voiceover he is
explaining to us the reasons for his
choices so we get a better understanding
of why he did something unlikable his
narration can be very powerful in that
way making casts more tolerant for the
terrible things he does tip number 3 how
to write compelling voiceover many
screenwriting books will tell you not to
use voiceover that it's a lazy device or
a crutch but Goodfellas is an excellent
reminder for what an amazing
screenwriting device it can be when done
right then Jimmy two-times who got that
nickname because he said everything
twice go get the papers get the paper
let's see how Scorsese creates such a
powerful voiceover Goodfellas basically
requires a voiceover because it's an
adaptation of the novel so it allows
Scorsese to get all the necessary
information into the film the voice-over
in Goodfellas complements good visual
storytelling rather than compensating
for a lack thereof it adds another layer
to what we see on the screen it's not
just a nice heel story but his inner
desires moved me a mint being somebody
in the neighborhood that was full of
nobodies it works so well because Crowe
says he uses voiceover with a distinct
purpose which is to be
an intimate relationship between the
character and the audience with
voiceover Henry becomes our tour guide
our Inside Man and lets us into this
underworld secretive organization a very
few people have access to Saturday night
was four wives but Friday night at the
Copa was always for the girlfriends we
feel privy to the inside information to
be able to know what's really going on
behind the curtains and the ins and outs
details of the mob life in New York if
you're part of a crew nobody ever tells
you that they're going to kill you and
the more secretive the subject matter is
the more you are interested and then be
right on your friends and always keep
your mouth shut
but remember this only works if the
subject matter is fascinating and if the
narrator is telling us the information
we don't already know voiceover can also
be used for the element of surprise and
in Goodfellas it is masterfully used for
a major story reversal Henry's narration
explains at length how Tommy will get
made and how Jimmy is happy for him at
this point in the movie we completely
trust a new generation see it's the
highest honor they can give you means
you belong to a family and a crew so
when the scene arrives and told me
instead of being made receives a bullet
in the back of the head it's pretty
shocking and a huge surprise for the
audience
Scorsese also uses narration to give
quick background information and
explainers in a clever way for example
he explains why they are called
Goodfellas you know we always called
each other Goodfellas like it's a to
somebody you're gonna like this guy he's
alright he's a good fella is one of us
voiceover can also be an efficient way
to show various perspectives on the
subject matter
besides Henry's we also have a voiceover
from Karen he was an exciting guy he
introduced me to everybody and with her
narration we get a female perspective
from the outside person and her also she
becomes fascinated with this world of
privileges and how and why she falls in
love with Henry which brings us to the
next tip tip number four how to
construct a riveting love story first
you must resist having characters
immediately like each other instant
attraction usually doesn't work in a
movie let the relationship
realistically evolve give them some
obstacles to overcome maybe make them
even hate each other in the beginning I
couldn't stand him Kenny and Karen were
forced to go on a first date and they
were bored Henry then also stood her up
on a second date those are some great
obstacles for the start of the
relationship then after the initial
obstacles create two scenes where the
lovers impress each other let's first
look how Karen impressed Henry she
impressed him because she had some balls
like the guys with whom he's hanging out
all day she also showed him the cheese
stuff and self-respecting then we have
Henry impressing Karen in a scene that's
probably the most famous tracking shot
in cinema ever Henry takes care through
the rear entrance of the Copa Cabana
Club in New York to a soundtrack of dan
he kiss me by the crystals it's an
ultimate seduction scene where she is
being introduced to his world with all
the privileges all doors open for them
and everybody wants to be their friend
in the third stage show the
strengthening of the relationship the
good and fun times together falling in
love getting married in stage 4 make
sure that the relationship gets tested
and this relationship gets tested a lot
an old friend harasses Karen will Henry
help her can we beat him up really bad
when she overlooked this extreme
violence Karen finds out he's cheating
on her what will she do Henry decides to
leave Karen would he go back home Henry
goes to jail we can help him now that he
is imprisoned now of course this is a
crime genre so the scenes can be
extremely dramatic and violent but in
every love story you need to invent
smart obstacles for your love couple
just modify them to your story world
also make sure to choose the right
characters with the right
characteristics for example in
Goodfellas Henry has girlfriends on the
side this is just a norm in a wiseguy
world he lives in now if Karen would be
a quiet polite woman who just accept
that like the other wise of Goodfellas
do then the relationship would fall flat
but because Karen has a short temper is
extremely jealous and fuses to let
Hannah of the
now we get some spectacular scenes I
knew the motivation of jealousy and
wanting to hold on through her man and I
understood those things also the scenes
of that relationship are very well
chosen they all served their purpose to
construct a strong love story while at
the same time they're very interesting
dramatic and suspenseful there are
amazing scenes in general and all very
memorable tip number 5 how to develop
memorable scenes Goodfellas has more
outstanding scenes than any movie should
be entitled to you already talked about
the opening scene and the Copacabana
scene but there is more
go get the shine box meet the mobsters
he think with Tommy's mom Prison garlic
slicing and the famous I'm going to kill
you look from Robert De Niro and we will
talk more about those scenes in our
patreon video but here we must dissect
one of the most memorable and
suspenseful scenes not just in
Goodfellas but in cinema in general how
am i funny scene let's find out why this
scene is so memorable first and most
important reason suspense the scene is
suspenseful just because we set up
beforehand the Tommy is this crazy
volatile character who can blow up in
any second
we're terrified of what he's capable of
I'm funny how I mean funny like I'm a
clown my you you I make you laugh second
thing the scene has conflict and stakes
the stakes are as high as possible Tommy
could kill Henry
right there in any second it has
reversals it starts out relaxed with
jokes but then bit by bit it becomes
more and more serious how am i funny
what is so funny about me Tommy
and then we get an unexpected surprise
and comic relief in the end
the scene also perfectly reveals
character we learn everything about Tom
in this interaction and what we can
expect from him later in the movie it
has visual action we have the waiter
come in and interrupt the scene after
which Tommy attacks him then we also
have people sitting around Tommy and
Henry and we see how their facial
expressions gradually change from
laughing to dreadful seriousness the
scene wouldn't be half as powerful if
that would be just Tommy and Henry in it
so if possible always include extra
characters this scene was improvised
from the actual events that happened to
actor Joe Pesci any Versalles actors
were given freedom to do and say
whatever they wanted once we had the
improv then then we had to lock it
Scorsese then made transcripts of these
rehearsals took the lines he liked the
most and then structured to scene with
dramatic principles if we take a close
look at the scene it has a flawless
structure it has a set up a call to
action turning point climax resolution a
new shoot structure scenes like little
short films if you really want to create
epic scenes
you should also copy Scorsese's process
take amusing situations from real life
improvise them then put them into a
proper dramatic structure with suspense
conflict and stakes and you will also
create amazing scenes now a very big
reason why this brilliant scene and many
other scenes in Goodfellas are so
memorable
is that Scorsese created such an
authentic world and how he managed to do
that we will explain in tip number six
in our patreon video for which you can
find the link in the description below
in this video on patreon we will also
talk about major story reversals how
music is connected to screenwriting and
also how to keep your readers constantly
on their toes with unpredictability if
you have any questions please leave them
in the comments below
and let us know your favorite tip or
favorite is tip number 5 how to develop
memorable scenes now go write your own
outstanding screenplays and we meet
again in the next video and now it's all
over